you mentioned January 6 and we do have
this story which just came out a couple
hours ago on Twitter everyone is uh
people are saying that Alex Jones has
flipped according to the New York Times
Alex Jones reached out to the justice
department about a January 6th interview
they say that uh through his lawyer Mr
Jones said he has given the government a
formal letter conveying his desire to
speak to Federal prosecutors the lawyer
Norm pattis maintained that Mr Jones had
not engaged in any criminal wrongdoing
that day when chanting slogans about
1776 as a condition of being interviewed
by federal investigators Mr Jones who is
known for his rants about the Deep State
and is supposed to is supposed to
control and it's supposed control over
National Affairs has requested immunity
from prosecution the first thing I would
say is I don't trust the New York Times
on stories like this but the other thing
I would say too is everyone's saying you
know it's met a lot of people on the
left they're like he's flipped I'm like
Alex Jones is on video yelling people
not yelling at them not to go near the
capitol that was a trap not to go in
he's not going to get immunity for
prosecuting first of all there were no
crimes that are being pursued here other
than perhaps against some of the January
6 defendants who actually committed
violent acts in violation of the law The
Alex Jones is of the world to the degree
they're facing any liability it's
because a corrupt uh prosecutions or
activity by the FBI doj and the
Democrats in Congress pushing them and
you know my understanding of the federal
system is that you don't get immunity
what they do is you plead guilty to a
crime
accept a punishment that might be
mitigated as a result of your
cooperation they don't give out
typically immunity for crimes they let
make you plea guilty so you know my
guess is Alex Jones wants to roll the
FBI and tell them the truth and tell
them the truth about uh what he did and
you know I believe he didn't do anything
wrong but uh you know so
the people who believe the the most
psychotic conspiracies about January 6.
believe in saying conspiracies about
what this is right now he's flipping oh
man he's there he's going to rent on
Trump yeah that's the crazy talk that
there's something to flip over yeah
right exactly so uh we had this this
really fun moment in January where I
said that uh
the people who were you know waved in to
the capitol or who walked up and the
cops opened the doors and said you know
let him come in and said I respect your
right to protest and took selfies with
with them these people it's how you
gonna Pro how do you get how are you
going to get them on trespassing how are
you going to get them on you know
trespassing in the capital if they're
invited in you won't be able to do it
and The Young Turks did this segment
where they were like Tim Poole is so
dumb he's so dumb and then what did we
see there's actually uh a guy got the
charges dismissed because he was like
they let me in the judge was like you're
right they did have a nice day good sir
so I imagine
there's a lot of people
who obviously the ones that were
fighting there was one guy who got his
charges dismissed relating to like
mischief and vandalism or something but
he got trespassed because the judge was
like yo you climbed over something to
get in there you knew you were
trespassing so there's we're going to
see the people who are violent get
charged we're going to see the people
who are let in probably a lot of these
people are going to start getting you
know not guilty please or not not guilty
verdicts but the people on the left who
are seeing the story right now because
they're tweeting about it this is the
exact same thing as the people who
thought Trump was was gonna show up on
March 3rd or whatever and walk into the
White House and that Joe Budden an ankle
bracelet or whatever an arrest and
arrest everyone yeah right yeah and it
ain't gonna happen and you know the real
Scandal is Contin you know we've sued
for all the records uh all the videos of
uh the capital we sued the Congress for
it we're in court Nancy Pelosi's
Congress is telling us that they have
sovereign immunity meaning they are
immune from lawsuit and none of the
record they're not public records and
even if they were the public interest
doesn't require their release so it's
the worst day in American history but
there's no public interest in releasing
the records so you know in my experience
when you don't want to release one
second of video even voluntarily
what are you hiding and I'm sorry guys
but you know this whole Michigan
collapse that Whitmer kidnapping
collapse means we should take a look at
if the FBI would break the rules there
did they break the rules in some of the
January 6 activities and I suspect we're
going to find out that's the case
absolutely I mean look anyone who knows
the name Ray apps can tell you that
there was almost certainly Foul Play
here and we should just say to them what
they've been saying to us over the fact
that they've been collecting people's
data in bulk if they have nothing to
hide then they should have nothing to
fear release the tape show us what
happens rayapse is interesting he was a
dude at the a rally whatever you want to
call it event the January 16th and he
was like yelling for people to go to the
Capitol I believe and they started
calling him a Fed they everyone started
yelling at home and then all of a sudden
he disappears and he's not prosecuted is
this right he turns up in a bunch of
videos encouraging people and inciting
them to Riot and not prosecuted with the
amount of spy Tech we have can you how
is that guy not being prosecuted what
about the the guy who planted the bombs
they didn't find in that person you
never found that that story just
disappeared yeah just completely
disappeared while and and supposedly
Harris is in the neighborhood yes Harris
was first didn't find it what the heck
is going on they said Kamala Harris was
right there that morning but then they
just stopped looking for the guy who
planted them apparently I mean God help
us you know I hate to get back to the
Secret Service you know they get
attacked you know the agents were
attacked for complaining about being
attacked by dogs we found out the Secret
Service top people or people in the
position to protect the president were
being targeted with a scam some type of
fraud by these two shysters in in uh in
DC they were offering them gifts and the
Secret Service didn't even figure out it
was going on I think it was the postal
inspection service that figured it out
so the Secret Service is kind of is is
dysfunctional and as someone who doesn't
want to see anyone in a position of
power harmed in the worst possible way I
worry about our security in the look
January 6 highlights that that we can't
the government can't protect us they
blew the security on January 6 the
capitol the Secret Service is just the
side as this of dysfunctional and these
are major issues I mean why is it we
think the Secret Service is any better
than any other government agency Olivia
Rondo went on Kennedy nation and said
something really profound and I hope I
get this right Olivia it's that the
government is there to serve us not to
take care of us remember that you're
here to serve us we put you there on
purpose so that you can work for us and
get this done right because we're all
Sovereign that's that's I I you're right
but at this point in our country in the
past hundred years it's just like
dude that's just not the case anymore
but that's the American Spirit without
it that's that's the nature that the
company the country's just a piece of
land where people are getting along next
door to each other if we don't have that
belief in common then it things can go
pretty we are we are seeing in in cities
democrat-controlled cities non-citizens
being granted the right to vote the
moment that happens you don't have a
country
like it's happening
the uh the the uh presidential election
the Electoral College is influenced by
non-citizens for uh I think there was
you know one or two votes in favor of
Democrats because of the amount of
illegal immigrants in California or
something like that
the congressional seats are not
apportioned based on citizen count
they're based on population count so if
you have a million non-citizens in one
area they're going to get an extra
congressional seat and an electro an
extra electoral vote these things are
ripping they're it's it's we're a ship
we're a big a big cruise ship those
things are holes in the ship and we are
taking on one I'm a realist or do you
think that we're just headed towards
globalization and we've got to figure
out how to roll with it oh well yes
absolutely okay I think so the issue is
uh to a certain degree globalization is
not a bad thing the bad thing is the
authoritarian takeover and the
destruction of our Sovereign our
sovereignty you can have international
agreements we can do away with war we
can have this beautiful planet but in
this area we have our own laws we make
our rules we live to according to our
values and things like that the problem
the problem is the world economic Forum
doesn't like our values the Davos group
doesn't like our values the values they
want for the world are more like China's
yeah I don't want to live that way so
that's the real problem is uh you know
we had a lot and he said he likes a
unipolar world he doesn't want China to
gain influence he wants the U.S to
dominate everything because our values
are better and I'm like he's being
honest about it and and we need to
recognize that in the world of the the
globalization as it's colloquially
understood is Chinese style social
Credit Systems
we can have a kind of international
relations that can you know end war and
have international courts where we
retain our sovereignty and our values
are persist do you think we're really
ever going to end War
so I think what likely would happen is
we may have already done it in the
traditional sense of how we we've we've
known it or be getting really close to
it uh obviously Ukraine and Russia right
now there's Hot War but will we break
past that point where it is just not
economically feasible or worth going to
war instead you'll see Shady dealings
soft power manipulation or fifth
generational Warfare so War conflict
will always exist in some form but we're
talking about Modern Warfare and we get
to the point where we're like kinetic
Warfare is fading away and now it's all
manipulation games it'll be
psychological manipulation well you know
this is this is uh Ukraine is kind of
the uh highlights that war is a feature
of the human condition and you know we
spent trillions of dollars in our
national security apparatus uh the
diplomacy usaid obviously that our
defense and intelligence establishments
to prevent war in Europe
and it happened in a heartbeat and you
know you could argue because of what
we've spent Ukraine isn't Luxembourg it
has 45 million people so this is not an
insignificant military action by the
Russians and we we paid these guys to
stop crap like that from happening and
they couldn't figure out how to stop a
gangster from going down the block and
breaking someone's window you know when
I'm exaggerating obviously for effect
there uh but Putin was stoppable and my
view is this is where the corruption
comes home to roost he sees Biden his
cognitive challenges he knows Biden's on
the take because he's on the take in
part from Russia based on the
information that's out there so he sees
a corrupted and firm repub leadership in
in our country and why not do what he
did I'm not saying it was the reason he
did it but some of the stoppers that
would have been in place as a result of
a competent strong America that wasn't
corrupted weren't the present and to me
that's the result is death and
destruction in Ukraine
yeah man that's why Integrity is so
important as an individual and as a
nation all of it because if you if you
are no longer your word is no longer
good no one's going to take you
seriously we had documents I love these
documents we found because you know I go
back to them all the time and there were
these documents just before Biden uh but
before Trump came in Biden went and
visited Ukraine
and the two top State Department
officials in Ukraine are talking about
his visit the anti-corruption visit and
these were the two officials who
testified against Trump and they were
talking three days before Trump came in
that Biden's there and the Russian press
is making fun of Biden's anti-corruption
issues because his son is on barisma and
they said that Trump the Russians were
trolling Biden and they and the state
department guy goes barisma is the gift
that keeps on giving
so you know we've got the state
department telling themselves they're
making fun of our country our foreign
policy objective let's say neutrally was
to stop corruption in Ukraine was being
hampered by the vice president's family
corruption and we're supposed to forget
that when Ukraine is invaded uh four
years later I think when Obama said
never uh what does something about never
never Overlook bidens of Joe's ability
to screw something up and he said
something along those lines he wasn't
joking yeah he didn't say screw yeah
[Laughter]
Joe Biden screws up words
I mean it's just it's an apparently
familial board corporate uh relations in
Ukraine too the hunter should have never
been on that board man that's nuts
yeah the the challenge we Face
internally is tribalism there are people
who have built careers off pandering and
they won't give it up it's true on the
rights true on the left but I think what
you have right now going on for the
right is that like I mentioned in the
post-liberal types people who are
Democrat voters before who are more
interested in principle and integrity
are sitting here being like look I can
watch Ben Shapiro Ben Shapiro will be
alike Joe Biden was engaged in corrupt
behavior in Ukraine and I'm like okay
and right okay again okay
it's really quite obvious based on the
tape we've seen thank you Sheamus and uh
and and I'm sitting here and I'm like
he's completely right and then he'll
come out with you know some political
position on policy as like as a response
and I'll be like well I disagree on you
on your your response position like but
if we agree on the facts that's what's
happening
any any sane reasonable person knows Joe
Biden was is crooked and doing crooked
things I mean flying his son on Air
Force 2 to China for a private Equity
deal why are using our resources for
that but you'll get these people on the
left who are just like didn't happen
didn't happen that's why they won't come
on this show
because they know we'll sit down and
I'll pull up all of the stories and all
of the videos and they'll just sit there
and listen to it and then they're gonna
have no choice when people are when
their fans are watching and like
I didn't know that it's like well
because they didn't tell you you know I
never understood well I guess I do
understand but politicians of both party
always misunderestimate is that the
right word uh misunderestimated that's
right that's a man I I almost forgot
about that I'm double I'm doubling down
on underestimating it the the corruption
is is a driving force for so much of the
Electoral public you know I you remember
when Nancy Pelosi came and took over
Congress in 2010 you know what her her
uh her big piece was her big slogan we
need to drain the swamp huh yeah so you
know and what happens is these
politicians run on battling corruption
in Washington DC at both parties and
then they get here
and it doesn't get done and in the case
of trump he actually did want to do
something and none of his appointees
thought it was important Republicans
don't care about battling corruption I
know there are exceptions and the
exceptions prove the rule Democrats have
Incorporated corruption unfortunately
into their governing governance style
they turned their offices in the case of
the vice president
into a racketeering operation so this is
um this to me there's opportunities on
both sides of the political aisle to run
on a reform anti-corruption agenda with
teeth thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segment events of
the timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there